ces élèves de CM2 sont pour la plupart
issus de milieux sociaux privilégiés
l'École alsacienne forme 1600 élèves de
la maternelle au baccalauréat beaucoup
de ministres et de nombreux acteurs
célèbres sortent de cette école privée à
9 ou 10 ans ses élèves ont déjà de
l'ambition mes cousins ils sont dans une
école et ils disent qu'ils aimeraient
bien être à ma place quand je leur
raconte ce qu'on fait un peu
Gabriel a 9 ans et demi ici il peut
pratiquer sa passion en toute liberté le
théâtre considéré comme n'importe quel
autre matière les pièces de Molière
n'ont plus de secrets pour lui et chaque
année il participe à un spectacle ah
voilà ma fille qui prend l'air elle ne
le voit pas elle soupire elle lève les
yeux au ciel papa travaille dans le
cinéma et il m'a dit que si on voulait
être un acteur célèbre il fallait
commencer par le théâtre l'année avant
dernière j'ai fait le chat botté et
j'étais le chat et l'année dernière j'ai
fait le Médecin volant et j'étais le
médecin allons donc